not my first co-star but my first day on
power because originally i booked it as
a co-star right um and then so you had
no idea that they're gonna keep you
around no so basically what happened is
i
i booked it as a co-star and i had two
scenes
and um it was just an [ __ ] like rich
white ccw character right so i it was
like a skeleton crew i worked as a local
hire so i lost like two thousand dollars
i flew myself in uh to because they
shoot that in new york i obviously live
here but my family's from rhode island
so i was like i'll make a trip out of it
yeah so i went providence right yeah
probably yeah
so i went to new york and we shot it um
and thank god the director because you
know the sides were i was trying to buy
pills from tariq my roommate at the
school chopin it was one scene and i'm
like yo let me let me buy pills and it
was just an [ __ ] wearing sperry's
this and that what are sperry's it's
like boat shoes it's like what every
rich [ __ ] from nantucket wears
are those those
[Applause]
but no the s just kind of came off the
bottom
yeah no those are cool those are
sneakers yeah those are all right i like
those
yeah
so the director was like okay the next
two takes are yours because i knew what
i was there for like i'm not trying to
make it about myself this and that i go
there i do what i was supposed to do and
whatever so she's like next two takes
yours so i just improv like crazy i
totally changed the character i made him
funny i didn't make him an [ __ ] you
know white character this snap which
kind of is the way it was written and i
just changed it and then you know a
couple months later when the show came
out that's what made the cut and nothing
that was originally written made it
so uh yeah it was really how do you
learn where did you learn to improvise
i've been i did on stage at ucb and
groundlings for years um i did i was
i performed pretty much at every indie
improv show in la for three years so
when she said the next two takes are
yours i was like got it i know what i
need to do but now are you improvising
with someone who knows what they're
doing as well um
my friend michael has been on the show
since he was 11 years old so he never
had to do any of that um so he he knows
how to improvise but like i i knew what
i was bringing to the scene it's not
about
you know a lot of people when they
improvise on like how do i give myself
more lines
and i know that that's the downfall
that's the pit of death because then
they're like oh it's like how do you
make this scene and this character
better how do you make the show better
right so that's the way i approached it
ah so then i got sure way beyond your
years my friend yeah and i was 21 at
that point 22
um when i when i shot that so then
whatever a couple months go by i saw it
and then they called me they said oh we
wrote you a whole story line for season
six so i was like oh dope so i come back
and they're paying you more they're
flying you out there find me out there
all right all right good so they wrote
me a whole story line and i show up and
the first person i see is 50 cent at
breakfast and he comes up to me and he
goes um
uh we like keep doing what you're doing
we loved you you killed it and i was
like holy [ __ ] like
because he's um yeah he's one of the
executive producers of the show he was a
main character on it for five seasons
four seasons um so it was just i was
like oh my god that's crazy and then the
show runner came up to me at the table
read um which i was so nervous for and
because my first table she came up to me
and she's like
keep doing what you're doing improv
whatever you want
add whatever in um i know you know what
you're doing and that kind of gave me
permission to just go because if the
showrunner was coming up with you and
say that
remember when you would fart every time
you could on set yes and everyone loved
it yes yeah remember when you used to
wear sandals and shorts because they
were only shooting you from the waist up
because it was too warm remember when
you had big feet i i
yeah talk though
what do you remember
listen anywhere you get your podcasts or
watch on youtube